hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast action sketching plus a
renowned leadership expert equals a more
impactful you I am Brenda Kelly Kim of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
lab leaders lab leaders is rocha's
promise to empower laboratories and the
people within them this is accomplished
by providing clinical and strategic
insights support and solutions from the
industry's top innovators near lab
leaders calm the 2016 lab leaders
webinar series and through el two
summits our lab leaders live events we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit your questions by typing them
in the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the c/e button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
Jeff Smith Jeff Smith has had a passion
for growing leaders and maximizing
individuals best talents for years as
the CEO of voltage leadership consulting
he is excited to share his passion for
professional and personal development
with your executives and high potential
employees Jeff brings over 20 years
worth of experience working as an
executive in human resources and
operations roles for both for-profit and
not-for-profit organizations he has
served as an executive coach since 2001
Jeff graduated [ __ ] laude with a BBA from
James Madison University management and
history he also
hold master's from George Washington
University and human resource
development additionally Jeff graduated
from Georgetown University with an
executive coaching and leadership
certificate became a fellow of the
advisory board in 2006 he earned his
professional coach certification through
the international coaching Federation
Jeff is married to Beth and they have
four children in his spare time Jeff
follows all J mu sports the Atlanta
Braves and runs marathons the action
sketching part of the webinar will be
delivered by ink factory Inc factory is
one of the world's most renowned studios
for graphic recording action sketch
videos in factories vision is a world
where visuals are the universal language
their mission is to create visual
experiences to inspire and engage while
actively listening to your discussion we
are synthesizing spoken words into
illustrative text and visuals I will now
turn it over to Jeff and the ink factory
thanks Brenda thanks / introduction and
gang I'm looking forward to this as well
there's gonna be a great experience
looking forward to it Brian as a team at
the ink factory come up with we're gonna
start is this is about how do we help
you reach peak performance via coaching
that you receive as well as coaching
that you're going to get to your team so
this will be a fast-paced moving around
talking about best practices and
coaching ideas to try and the ability to
put this into action so you can see real
quick this is the business that I run
its voltage leadership consulting you
can see we do some various activities
and you know I'm really excited to be
here with you today haven't been in the
lab interesting working with you many of
you across the country and many of you
across the world you post at workshops
anywhere from Roanoke to Abu Dhabi as
you can see here I'm getting coached
some from my friend Omar we're getting
ready to go dune bashing right outside
Abu Dhabi some of you ray may recognize
it from the recent Star Wars movie this
is where they filmed a lot of the star
wars and I'm going to be coached on how
to jump over those major hills and I am
honestly a little scared there but
luckily
r is a great coach and teaching me how
to do it but first we had to have some
hands-on coaching as you can see here so
Omar had to get the camels all throwed
so we could get there some of you I'm
sure feel this way when you're trying to
lead your team's it can feel like
leading the herd of camels we're going
to give you a few ideas on the best way
to motivate and engage your team today
but it has been a great experience
working with Cleveland Clinic Abu Dhabi
they've just opened a new hospital there
we were able to do a serving leader
program and get to teach coaching and
leadership skills in a new part of the
world and they have 3,300 people now
trained and operating in Abu Dhabi so
let's start with you now why should I
trust you this is a great question one
of things that may keep you from
training and coaching your team right
now is there's a gap between what your
folks feel and how much they are
trusting you with their career with
their ideas with their dreams hopes and
aspirations so why should the people
that you are coaching trust you do you
trust your leader if so why are why not
another question I might have for it is
why are you not touching your team right
now many of you I know the first answer
is going to be time I know how busy are
I work in the labs I see you guys
understand the challenges do more with
less go faster here we got new
certifications we get done there's a you
know Joint Commission coming in or cap
is coming in for inspection but if
you're not coaching right now somebody
is looking to take your talent they're
going to need it in their organization
and so coaching will allow you to be
able to connect with your team keep them
motivated and engaged my other question
for you is why are you not getting
coached it's good enough for athletes
piano players artists singers all get
coached why do we not take the time to
get coached so a lot of times it will
come down to this issue of trust am I
ready to trust you with my career my
hopes my dreams my concerns so who do
you trust well
for some they trust Fox News that's
where they go to get their information
what are the people that are in your
team go to get their information in our
house we trust Fox News for things like
the debates my kids think of them for
things like American Idol football and
back in the old days for me maybe 24 how
about CNN who trust CNN for me I always
think back to early days of CNN and
their war coverage in 1991 I also travel
a lot internationally and so for me a
lot of times it's going to be that
international traveler CNN is that place
where I can go and feel like I've gotten
real good information about the United
States who do you trust it could be your
boss maybe you trust Warren Buffett for
your financial advice maybe it's Oprah
Winfrey for influence maybe it is a
leader in your community maybe it's a
former boss but at some point you've
trucked to somebody with your hopes and
dreams with your desires that's the
start for a coaching relationship is it
trust and so I really want you to think
about who do you trust and why do you
trust them the first resource I'm going
to offer to you is a book called thanks
for the feedback the science and art of
receiving feedback well this is from a
Doug stone and Sheila hon you may
recognize Doug stone from the book
difficult conversation and what they
talk about in the book is that feedback
is really three different things with
different person purposes the first is
appreciation this is about how do you
motivate and encourage the second is
coaching this helps increase knowledge
skill capabilities it will help you grow
and it raises good feelings in the
relationships the third is evaluation
evaluation is telling you where do you
stand aligning expectations and making
sure that you are able to make good
decisions and know where your
decision-making is allowed to go so
again it's the ACE model appreciation
coaching and evaluation will cover in
some more detail as we
go throughout the presentation what I
want you to understand though is that
evaluation as you can imagine that's the
one that the loudest voice it can drown
out the other two and so we always can
understand that part of our job as
leaders is to give evaluation and we are
supposed to be there to help our team
understand holiday performing and that's
a valuable resource because before can
really be coached I have to know how I'm
doing what matters though is what is
your mindset as you go into the coaching
are you going into the coaching thinking
I'm going to correct the people that
work for me I'm going to make sure that
they know what they're doing is wrong if
you're going into a relationship a
conversation with that kind of attitude
then you're probably going to get a lot
of offensiveness and the coaching is not
going to work very well so what we
talked about trying to encourage you
with coaching is instead of that's wrong
shift to an attitude of sharing what
you're seeing but wanting them to say
tell me more about how I can get better
so maybe the question should be here's
what I'm seeing tell me about when
you've been your best what can I do as
your leader to help you be at your best
more consistently so really it's about
having the right conversation with the
right people at the right time and the
right intent will play with that concept
a little bit more in a couple slides
moving on this first model of the day
and so this is how do you really
understand peak performance and gain the
most out of your high potential people
that are on your staff and gang that's
everybody everybody that you hire has
potential and you've got the ability to
grow and develop them and I want you to
think back to when you hired them you're
so excited about the potential of this
person joining the organization in the
first 30 or six days you stayed so
connected with them you were helping
them understand expectations you
probably recognize their efforts some
you may even gave a feedback and refine
their performance but then you get busy
they get busy and sometimes we slip
and so what we're asking you to think
about is when you've got someone on your
team have you done all of these so let's
go through the model in a little more
detail will be referring back to small
throughout the rest of the presentation
so next our goal is to have motivate and
engage employees as I travel around the
US speaking I hear this all the time
Jeff my folks just don't seem to be that
motivated how do you deal with a person
who doesn't seem to be motivated how do
I make sure that they stay motivated
they stay with our company how can i get
my engagement scores up well let's look
at this slot at the bottom is really
where we need to start and if how do I
work so what we're looking for are where
are the goals from our role were the
tools that need to do the job what are
the things that matter do I understand
that if I don't understand that it's
really hard for me to understand and buy
into your vision once I understand the
consequences understand the goals then I
can perform for you if you move to the
next level you can see that the
motivation engagement starts to get
better once I know my goals and move up
if someone recognizing me are you giving
me praise do you give me the opportunity
to try some new things does it seem like
you care if I start to see that then I'm
ready for feedback from you because I
know you care about me I know you care
about me doing a good job and I'm ready
to succeed further how do I contribute
do I have influence around what we do
around here it might allow some
ownership so many of the labs I work
with they're now doing lean and 5s
events and what the benefit of that is
is we go when we ask employees what is
it that we can do around here to make
our organization run more smoothly and
we ask for their input and so at the end
of a day where we've done 5s and had a
lean intervention the employees came up
with the solutions get the buy-in get it
implemented and start using a new
process the very next day in the lab
they go back to the bench excited
and the reason that is they saw that
they had some ownership some say and
they're able to build relationships with
peers that they couldn't have done
before that when you're able to do that
the organization moves forward and now I
am ready to grow with you so when you
ask me about what it is that my career
goals are if I'm thinking about going
into a management role I'm going to look
and say have you built trust with me
through these other levels have you
given me clear goals you recognize me
have you love me had a chance to
contribute and now I'm ready to work
with you and to really be coached a
quick story from my own experience and I
was a leader at Capital One and one of
the things that happened was a door need
to be fixed the CEO was coming to the
company to do a town hall and I feel so
excited about you know we've got about
2025 my employees I'm responsible for
and the CEO is taken time out of his day
to come to us the week before we've been
on Business Week magazines front cover
about one of the most exciting places to
work so I've got everyone prepped I've
shared the vision here's what we're
going to do and there's gonna be all
kind of growth and excitement for you
wait till you hear from rich and so it
gives a lovely presentation and he opens
it up like I will do at the end to some
questions and the very first question
that they asked was when can we get the
door fixed I was like mortified I'm like
oh my gosh he went on he answered the
question and we had a conversation
afterwards I found him and just said
rich and I'm really sorry about that he
goes Jeff this is a great leadership
opportunity for you if you can get the
door fix they'll buy into your vision
but it's the little things that matter
and so think about the lab do you have
good benches do they have the equipment
that they need for some that were scrubs
do they like the scrubs the first time
we went into one of our labs that we had
acquired that was the first thing they
asked for they said we don't like the
color the scrubs so before they bought
the vision that we were sharing they
need to know that we cared about them so
go to the bottom and do you help them
understand their roles and then start to
move up that's the basis of coaching
relationship so what's my role where do
I fit in again give me clear
expectations
give me the resources do my job and help
me understand how I fit into the culture
because I want to do a good job around
here I need to know what matters so make
sure you still in from me what matters
what you care about where they keep a
Hagar's I want to do the behaviors for
you but I got to know what you care
about and I got to see you role model
them if I see you role model them then I
know how to fit in and know how to make
a difference here next make sure i know
my authority what are my
responsibilities what decisions can i
make i will tell you that there is an
excellent book out there that if you
need some help setting some clear goals
and being able to really help get down
to specific expectations it's book
called winning with accountability I'll
repeat that winning with accountability
and it's a great tool for setting
expectations getting employees to
understand what they need to do and
being able to have a clear understanding
of the goals and how to reward the goals
so again winning with accountability by
Henry Evans so my final thought on this
slide would be resistance is often just
a lack of clarity resistance is just a
lack of clarity and so if you're seeing
resistance the first time instead of you
thinking that that's a limb problem I
would have you look and say have I given
them clear expectations have I given the
tools to know how do the job if i sat
down with them and really explain what
matters around here how we're going to
measure how are they going to be
assessed at the end of the year into the
quarter end of the week until i know
that i may wait because i don't want to
mess something up and so if you're
seeing some resistance try to go back to
some clear expectations ultimately if
you give them clear expectations and
then there's resistance we'll talk about
some ways that we can overcome that
later in the presentation the next part
is do you appreciate me if you can see
on the slide here the brain is lighting
up this is an actual brain and showing
the parts of the brain when I get
recognized how it lights up I call it
lighting up the christmas tree
we all have folks that you know when
you've given them the compliment you can
just see them excitement and enjoy that
they have one of my daughters you know
she will blush so all feedback is a gift
but it's not a gift it's either is
easily received no matter whether we
fight it or we blush or warm up all
feedback will be stuff that will have an
impact on us whether it's our brain or
body but you know we really do like to
get positive recognition what's the
right amount you may be asking up to one
ratio is the right amount so 5s for
every negative comment unfortunately
most organizations are at a one-to-one
so it's one positive statement for every
negative statement unfortunately in
health care many of our organizations
are too negative for every positive so
again the ratio is 5 positive for one
negative some of you may be saying gosh
up that seems really pint pollyannaish
people do make mistakes absolutely and
here's the deal we're good at
recognizing those we have a hard time
taking a moment to be able to recognize
folks and I get it a lot of your busy
and may not have the time you feel like
so a couple tips one be authentic don't
give them a feedback on just something
like okay wow I really appreciate that
you moved X to Y when that's just
something really basic no really be
authentic set up a plan maybe it's an
Excel spreadsheet where you go in and
say how much feedback have you given to
each person this week put some time on
your calendar to walk around the lab and
it give positive feedback you can give
corrective feedback at the same time but
be really intentional another idea is
have your people whether it's your
direct reports your technicians or your
supervisors send you an email each week
saying something positive that's
happened on your team it gives you a
great chance to be able to walk out of
your area go to the lab and be able to
say thanks for something that's gone
well it will do amazing
for your motivation engagement another
resource to check out they've got some
videos on YouTube as well as a book is
called the carrot principal again it's
the carrot principal and basically their
feedback says that people say that
sixty-four percent of the people
surveyed said they had not been had a
positive recognition in the past year
now probably did happen that they had
the recognition but they're feeling was
they had not been recognized throughout
the past year probably because there was
so much negative recognition did it
drown the positive so again five
positive for every negative put it on
the calendar pull up on the bench and
sit next to someone and give some
feedback next this moves into the
valuation phase would you review with me
what's going right what have I done
correctly and what do I need to do
differently another great way of asking
this is are there things I need to start
doing stop doing and continue really be
specific and I would tell you have the
courage to be direct too many leaders I
work with especially in health care we
like to really take care of folks in
healthcare want to kind of water it down
the more direct you can be in and being
honest with them the better the chance
now that doesn't mean being mean that's
being direct and be able to share the
feedback in a direct manner so that your
intent is to build them up not tear them
down but by being direct they know
exactly what they need to do a great
question to to talk to the person about
is here's why I feel you're doing really
well and the more often you can do this
the better real be then asking them how
is it you can do your best work on a
more regular basis how can you do your
best work on a more regular basis see
what they come up with and it didn't
build from that move to the next slide
which type of feedback do you provide
more often so there's three types
appreciation evaluation and coaching in
evaluation and coaching what we find is
that many of our leaders they spend so
much time in evaluation that we never
quite get to coaching
so the difference is on this
presentation if you're seeing me live I
like to talk with my hands and so the
valuation would be Jeff you spent
twenty-seven percent of your time with
your hands flying everywhere and it was
distracting so luckily I'm not on video
this one so you don't see the hands
flying around coaching would be Jeff I
noticed that you use your hands a lot
when you speak what would you like to do
to improve your performance around how
you use your hands the evaluation is
important I need to know where I stand
but if that's all I ever get from you is
evaluation after a while I feel beat
down so is your intent to build me up or
is you intend to tear me down when you
have coaching I moved from the
evaluation phase two okay now that we
know how you stand let's work on
building you up what can we do to help
you get stronger at this how can I help
you be better if you're working with
your leaders your question to your boss
or your leader could be okay I
appreciate the evaluation can you help
me think through some ways that I can
get better at this can we brainstorm
some ways and then put together a plan
it's becoming a partnership now and in
that partnership it allows me to trust
you and allows us to be able to form the
kind of relationship where i can get the
feedback get some evaluation but also to
move myself forward when you help me
improve my performance what's going to
happen is I'm going to trust you with
here's what I'd like to do here's where
I see myself in the lab and be able to
grow my skills which leads to again
greater collaboration or as the slide
says it is coaching is a collaboration
helped me refine what I'm doing and
change so question I have for you is are
you in the mood of almost a competition
with your employees are you to spot
where you're you're nervous that they
may take your job or you nervous that
they may be better at you and then and
some aspects of the role what I'd ask
you to do is suspend that you know what
you should be hiring people they're
smarter more talented than you why
because that will push you
it will give you the capacity to maybe
work on the next big thing the next
process to put in place the next idea
maybe it's time to bring lean into your
lab so that you can make the lab jump
forward maybe it's that partnership with
the blood bank so that you can better
serve your patients but if you are
always trying to be the smartest person
in the room and view it as a competition
with your direct reports very hard to
build trust very hard for you to be able
to connect and it will keep your folks
from being able to get engaged and
motivated so start to look and say as
I'm getting ready to go have a coaching
and feedback conversation with my direct
reports am I on the mode of coming and
to give criticism to correct or am i
coming in a place with my intent is yes
I have some feedback but I want to talk
about what's going right and I want to
talk about how do we help you get
stronger and better and here a couple
things I'm noticing there are two very
different ways of coming at it and the
best partnerships and the ways I trust
you is when it's a collaboration you
give me feedback what I'm doing well and
you helped me grow my skills so are you
allowing your point to learn are you
letting them grow some of you say well
gosh f you know when do I have time and
does it have to be formal do I have to
go to an office and the answer is no
koshin doesn't have to be formal you can
absolutely pull up to the bench and have
a conversation some of the best coaching
is absolutely going to happen there if
you go all the way back to Omar with me
and in the desert there you know his
coaching right before I was getting into
the four-wheeler helped me really calm
down additionally him showing how to
move camels help me understand when I
was dealing with camel later that day so
some hands-on coaching at the desk or at
the bench absolutely a wonderful thing
to do so be willing to pull the bench
have a conversation what I would ask you
to think about though is what is your
intent and so as you are coming to give
that feedback again is your intent to
help build the person up to be able to
show them a few things that if they do
this a little better they're going to be
great
are you also taken some time to
recognize them for a job well done so
again going backwards do you have some
ideas of the work that they've done so
you can celebrate it you can also always
have a coffee go for a chat be able to
maybe take a walk outside until two
birds with one stone I know many of you
are in wellness programs some of my best
coaching sessions are in 15 and 20
minute walks because we're not always
face to face it makes it a little less
intense so be willing to think about
coaching in new and different places
here's a tool that I think will help you
as you start the conversations so this
is called the structural tension model a
really good book that highlights this
model is called the power of Ted and
it's got things like the dreaded drama
triangle in it and then Powerman dynamic
I won't go into that into detail today
when there's not enough time but one of
the models i do like from it is the
structural tension model and basically
this is how you can start a coaching
session a team meeting a project review
look at the top what is the ideal state
another way of asking that is what is
your desired outcome what is it that
we're hoping to accomplish in our
one-on-one together in our time together
in the team meeting in the project
review we then go down to what's the
current reality where are we now
relation to our desired outcome the
current reality could be gosh four days
behind it could be you know we're only
at ninety-seven percent efficiency in
the lab and our goal is 98.2 percent so
how are we going to get there what I
know is that we're really good at
current reality conversation we struggle
to start with the conversation around
what's been working well what is our
desired outcome so I challenge for you
would be can you start a coaching
session with what's our desired outcome
or team meeting with what's the desired
outcome for the team today instead of
comes with your own agenda so think
about this the reason the rubber bands
here let me explain it if you can just
picture a robe and being pulled between
my two thumbs the top thumb is the
desired outcome what's the ideal state
the
bottom thumb is what is the current
reality so I can just picture that Ryan
and the team from Inc factor is drawn
away crazy some rubber bands and
wondering where I'm going but stay with
me so the top is the ideal state if I
let my thumb go on the bottom of our
band I get rid of current reality so if
i only have ideal state the challenge
with that is that that's all vision
that's all talk and we never get down to
the practical how are we going to do
this differently our lab how are we
going to get to the ninety-eight percent
quality measure that we're hoping for
now the flip that is we pull the rubber
band again but we get rid of the top
part we get rid of the desired outcomes
and we only have current reality this is
many of the labs main healthcare and
truthfully non health organizations I
work with we are all stuck in current
reality the downside of that is we only
do the transactional things so a lot of
our one-on-one just deal with what's
happened in the last day two days we
never get to the transformational what
are the possibility what's the ideal
state and so we really want tension but
we want to ease the tension so the way
to do that is ask these questions so
after we established desired outcome
current reality we then ask the question
what are our assets resources what are
our strengths what's working well and
that's not safe there's not berries you
can see down the right-hand side what
barriers may be hindering us great well
how do we leverage our strength to
overcome those barriers and let's put
some baby steps in place so if you think
about coaching session we go from our
desired outcome so here's our current
reality ok well let's talk about how do
we close that gap whenever we done that
well and how do we change that so
ultimately we're able to have a
conversation about baby steps that's a
coaching session it's also really good
at reinforcing asset-based thinking how
do we reinforce our strengths and our
possibilities and not get so hung up on
some of our challenges in the current
reality so again this is a great tool to
try maybe in your next one-on-one let's
talk about 10 ones and some best
practices so you can see a bunch of
bubbles here I'm just going to walk
through a few of my point
here many of folks that I coach they say
Jeff I really want to do this but I
don't know how well let's start with the
primary focus should be on the ploy too
often what happens is we the leader come
in and drive our own agenda it's all
about our desired outcomes hey it's okay
sometimes it should be about us and
sometimes you need it to be about you
but again coaching is a collaboration
and so if you can come in and say okay
you know Erica what is your desired
outcome from our time together and she
lifts off three things that's a great
I've got about two things I'd like to
cover looks like we've got a 24-hour
time today what do you want to start you
can see that you're given them some
ownership of this time it's a 50-50
partnership it's not just coming to the
boss and reporting out it's now a
partnership but make sure that you
understand what the boy hopes to get out
of it because they've been thinking
about this one-on-one maybe all week
maybe all month and now they're finally
ready to come and talk to you and so if
you come in with your own agenda and
don't ask any questions they're going to
walk out demotivate and not engage
another thing to watch for is make sure
its regular best practices is weekly now
some of you have so many direct reports
that may not be practical say may have
to split up maybe your supervisors or
leads can help with some of the regular
one on once again it doesn't always have
to be scheduled in an office it could be
that that one on one is by the bench and
that may be the best way that you can
handle it but do try to get some privacy
from some from time to time to take on
some deeper issues watch rescheduling
though because what happens often is
that you're busy an important meeting
comes up something didn't go right
overnight and next thing you know you've
just bumped three of your one-on-ones
well I may have been waiting all week or
two weeks waiting for this conversation
I'm so excited you know I've told my in
my case Beth my wife that morning I'm
going to have a conversation my boss and
so then you bump me you can just see
what's happening to my motivation my
engagement so making sure that really
try to honor and don't reschedule
next is be present and this is really
being present this isn't checking your
two different smartphones this isn't
looking back at the data that's on your
computer this isn't seen who's in the
hallway this is putting those things
down and really have a one-on-one
conversation if you're looking to save
time lots of you scheduled one-on-ones
for an hour or 45 minutes but then
you're distracted a really great
one-on-one can be 20 minutes of ten ten
time with each person and if you can put
away the scratch distractions it will be
able to go quickly so are you really
present are you really looking at them
eye to eye and having the conversation
follow up well seems pretty self
explanatory but you take a lot of notes
and if you commit to actions make sure
you take those actions again a trust
breaker is I left you with a couple
things to do and you didn't follow
through I start to wonder if you really
care about me so if you commit to doing
something make sure you do it this next
tent in concept is it should really be
about 10 minutes of them talking about
10 minutes of you talking and maybe
about 10 minutes of developmental so
that higher-level conversation and so if
you find yourself doing Apes of the
talking you're missing out on the core
concept of the one-on-one and if they're
all transactional and only business and
there's never what are your hopes and
dreams then after a while I wonder if
you really care about me do you really
care about where I am in the
organization and so making sure you get
to that developmental conversation to
help you get to that developmental
conversation the next slide can help in
that coaching conversation so once
you've established goals and
expectations and you've helped me
understand what to do you give me some
recognition you give me some evaluation
of how I performed you I've accepted
feedback I've grown I've developed I'm
ready to really be in that coaching
relationship with you and so this model
is one that I use still in my coaching
practice it's called the iGrow model the
first is what's intention what are both
you and the other person coming into the
meeting hoping for so really for you as
a coach you should declare in your mind
before you get there what is your
intention what
you hoping to achieve in your own mind
then we should probably have some sort
of goal that we're working on long-term
so it may be I'm working on getting
better at budgeting maybe I'm working on
my influence and how to get some my idea
is accepted by other parts of the lab or
maybe if you know i'm going to branch
out and i have a goal of growing and i'm
going to need a partner with the nurses
in the hospital and so being able to say
what is the goal that we're really
talking about the next step is reality
so what's been happening what am I
seeing here's the progress I've made
what our options that given that reality
where the options of or the
possibilities and then finally what's
next and the what's next is what's the
next action i'm going to take let me
just give you a concrete example for my
days at working in a healthcare system
for directors to be able to be a
director in our healthcare organization
you had to have a master's degree so i
came in knowing that the person I was
talking to did not have their master's
degree but they had a desire to move up
to the organization so as I was sitting
down to coach Joyce the intention was
how can I help her achieve her goals and
her goal was she want to be a director
in the next six months we then went to
the reality and said well Joyce let's
talk about that you need to be having
your masters before you can be a
director so it's six months realistic
tell me what you've done to start the
program I've done anything well then
reality is we probably can't get there
because oh well that really is no fun
look coaching isn't always easy I had to
be honest with her and tell her that's
not going to happen in six months so
instead we came up with some options
saying what is the best path for her and
we were able to find a night and weekend
kind of program she worked days where
she was going to be able to complete her
master's in 18 months her next step was
to go research and come back at our next
session be able say exactly what she'd
done and which schools did she think
we're best going to fit her and then
could the the system aizen afford to pay
for that so that's an example that that
conversation really only took about 10
or 12 minutes
but she left empowered inspired and she
walked away with the work to do so it's
a sample of how you can use the iGrow
method on the next page I'm not going to
go into a la detail this is a leave
behind but as you're trying to discover
the reality these are just questions
that you might want to explore and so
when you're sitting down to do that
first one you might be a little nervous
about how to do the session so what I
want to do is just leave you some
questions my favorite question probably
how this is what do you have tried
already what actions what difference did
those actions make I want to understand
what they've tried I don't want to
assume anything I want to hear their own
it also helps me understand how
committed are they had they start to try
to do some things and are they committed
to their own growth and development so
for that person that is not motivated
doesn't seem to want to do anything this
is one of those tests a litmus test to
say well let's talk about what you've
tried what are your ideas if they don't
do anything between your first
conversation the second one give them a
second chance but notice and just say
here's what I noticed you seem to be
very excited but I don't see any action
for me to continue to give you the
coaching time and may they be able to
really help you you're going to have
take responsibility for that if they
continue to not do that then you start
to have to ask the question are they
right for the organization because each
person needs to be getting better year
over a year you have to be a better year
and they're not getting there you may
have to deliver a tough message saying
we got to get better so again as you're
sitting down to do your coaching session
for the first time there's some great
questions here another set of questions
i really like can both be feedback for
yourself but feedback for the folks
you're coaching what do you need to
start doing and what do you need to stop
doing and so asking them how can I help
best support you you can ask them what
do I need to start doing to support you
better what is I need to stop doing so
that can be a more effective leader and
coach for you but you can also ask them
the same question what is it they need
to start doing so that they can be the
best person on your team that they can
be this builds off the lean you can also
obviously due to continue but being able
to sit down and have this kind of
conversation starts to build that trust
then if you're able to go and actually
do some research for them on maybe the
school their choice maybe it's getting
them exposed to another part of the
organization they're going to start to
buy into you and trust some of your
ideas the hardest part is often getting
started so the best suggestion i have is
sketch out your first coaching session
how do you get started well you're going
to have to practice so start with a
strong employee again sketch out what is
that you want to talk about maybe even
have the person have the structural
tension model i use that often in my
coaching sessions with leaders and with
teams and what I'll do is I'll
officially give them the structural
tension model and say let's just walk
through this together what is your
desired outcome what do you hope to get
out of this time that we're going to
have together what do you hope to get
out of this year if you're kicking off
the performance review then you can say
great what's the current reality so
check in around do you understand the
expectations do you have the tools to do
your job do you know what matters around
here do you get regular feedback what do
you need me to start doing and stop
doing see how it all starts come
together then as they are starting to
think about that make sure you highlight
some of the strengths you see and why
you think they can do what what their
goal is that's the positive recognition
then when there's barriers and they say
well I can't get to because maybe
there's not funding for this or there's
naught X or Y or Z saying okay let's
brainstorm where are some possibilities
so again that helps them show that
they've got some ownership say and
influence here and then you can say you
can give ideas the coach can brainstorm
give ideas ultimately you want to go
with idea
them that the employees the most excited
about though and not your idea if you
find new yourself always given advice
then that's probably in the role of
advice giver and you're probably not in
coaching you should bother be in the
space where you're giving suggestions
asking questions but they choose the
course action and so that ultimately
they're the ones to declare this is my
next set of action steps and your wrap
up question should be what is it that
you need for me to help support you
teach your goals and when they hit their
goals have a great celebration so I was
just with one of my folks that coach
down at carolinas HealthCare and she
finished her master's this week so we
had a wonderful celebration on the phone
but more impressive was that her leader
and her team brought in balloons cake a
certificate and they bought her a charm
for bracelet this was a huge celebration
for her it was something she'd been
working diligently for the last two
years and it all came together with
great coaching great partnership between
a great collaboration between her and
her leader and ultimately ended up in a
wonderful celebration and in our
coaching session yesterday she was just
bouncing with joy and you could just
feel it that can be the excitement of
coaching yes it's going to take some
practice to start with a star employee
it will be easier they probably don't
get as much recognition as they deserve
and they'll be so excited you care about
their career so again start with a
superstar then when you want to move on
to more challenging conversation
practice it with a peer so that you're
ready for the challenging ones next and
the final five remain curious the reason
I say that is often we've been working
with people for a year 5 10 15 and the
health care maybe 40 years but that
doesn't mean that they haven't changed
and they don't want to grow and develop
so don't put them in a box and say oh
that's the person that is always going
to be in this area they're always going
to be a history check or they're always
going to be a phlebotomist know be
curious ask some questions give them
some feedback and say what is it that
you're hoping to accomplish and
how can I help you hit the goals that
you're trying for really get curious
about what people care about but also
for you share your own curiosity with
your boss and say here's what I want to
learn here's how I grow and I hope that
part of it is that you use the iGrow
model to have a coaching conversation
with some of the people in your team and
just be curious to see how it works and
maybe give me some feedback on how it
went so thank you for your attention
will now have some time for questions
I'm going to turn it back over lab roots
so that we can address some of your
questions in just a moment thank you
thank you Jeff thank you Jeff for
bringing that informative presentation
to us I just like to draw the audience's
attention to the image on the screen
that is what was created by ink factory
it contains many of these stories and
takeaways that Jeff talked about with us
today a copy of this image will be
available on lad leaders calm after the
event today I also want to let our
audience know how they can submit their
questions for our question and answer
session you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window will try to get to
as many of your questions as we can
today our first question an attendee
asks how do I start coaching yeah that's
a great question so I would say sorry my
voice is going horse here the coaching
is one of the hat you wear at manager
and so I would just say it to know that
we're always coaching in some form or
format whether it's the evaluation
cochin where we're given the feedback to
the folks or it's sitting down and
talking about what's going on with their
goals what they're hoping to accomplish
so I think the first thing to start I go
all the way back to the trust it's
asking them the question of how can I
best support you and seeing that they're
open first
to coaching but then it's also saying if
they're coming and saying i'd really
like to get some feedback I'd like to
know where I stand they'll often open
that door say great well we tell me a
little bit about what is your desired
outcome what are you hoping to do so i
think it's setting us at the time
knowing that you'll need the folks to to
be able to be able to receive feedback
and so have you laid the foundation
where we trust each other and are able
to build that relationship I think
that's how you start at the coaching
great great answer you have another
question what do i do if i don't have
any budget for training or projects how
do I still support my employees goals to
answer a question right now I that's
probably one I hear the most you know I
think that a lot of things don't require
budget so what are some assignments that
are happening around your lab around the
health care system organization that
you're in can you put them on some
projects let them have a chance to go
try some things now you have to be
intentional don't just sort of dumped
work on people you have to sort of say
what is it that you're trying to achieve
let me understand the goal and then
let's see if we can't find some
activities that we can give you in the
workplace other things that I've seen
our groups have gone in and they bought
their own books and a book study and so
given them the time to be able to have a
book study yes there's some costs
associated with that just from the time
but trying to do it maybe when the lab
is slightly less busy I know it's always
busy but are there some times where
maybe we could get together and do a
book setting additionally and what I've
seen a lot is allowing folks to be able
to get a certification often is allowed
and or pay for the organization so try
to make sure that you say who should be
certified and allowing them to grow and
develop a net finally I see a lot of
people they can do volunteer work so
let's say that you want to be a manager
but you never have managed a budget then
volunteer for a not-for-profit
organization and learn how to do
budgeting outside of the workplace so it
doesn't all have to happen in the
workplace but it's being able to sit
down and brainstorm with person that's
working with you too
find some solutions so there's a few
ideas Britain played a sound good
concerning books what books can I read
to learn more about coaching yes you
know I think the book did I recommend if
you're really interested in coaching is
something called co-active coaching and
by the authors are Kinsey house and so
again it's co-active coaching another
one is the coaching mindset that's by
chad hall and then finally the coaching
habit by Michael stay near st aan i er
each one of these does different things
like the co-active coaching has got lots
of questions you could ask it has things
like the iGrow model in it and it has
the questions the coaching habit that's
probably better for the manager that is
really busy and says how do I just learn
enough about coaching to understand the
mindset and that's one of my roles and
and then the coaching mindset that's
maybe build on the coaching habit one so
the coaching habit is really good for
the manager to understand it and then
build on it with the coaching mindset
great here's a question I'm sure you get
a lot what can I do with a person that
does not want to be coached and firings
not an option okay so we'll start from
there uh you know because it generally
that's the first thing catches fire them
and the answer is no we unfortunately
most times no you know i think it's a
it's starting with trying to understand
what is it that they're trying to
achieve and then they may be quiet and
say you know i'd say want to i don't
want to grow i just want to come in and
do my job you know I kind of like the
status quo so I think it's trying to
find that spot where okay let's talk
about where you are doing well in the
job if they're not doing well in the
jobs and this is probably a different
kind of coaching we should probably be
dealing with performance and let's just
manage up their performance if this
though is this is a pretty stable person
but no real interesting
rowing did you know maybe their work is
only the second or third priority you
know they're much more concerned about
family or school then I think it just
becomes a okay how can I help you be
better day in and day out so I think
it's starting with a different question
of saying I'm not necessarily trying to
make you into a manager and I'm not
necessarily trying to make it super star
but I do want to help you be better day
in and day out I'd also let them know
that if we don't grow and I mentioned
this earlier in the presentation if we
don't grow sort of each year we have to
get better and generally we need to get
better about that ten to fifteen percent
year-over-year so if you're not growing
in two or three years you won't be
meeting expectations and a lot of people
don't think about that way and so I
think it's sitting down with them trying
to understand what it is that that that
has him saying that they don't want to
grow I laugh because my mom through a
lot of her career she would kind of give
that response that wasn't what I want to
do but then what she really didn't want
to be was the best at her job but she
only wanted to work a 40-hour work week
and then be done and get home to family
once her boss understood that they can't
hurt great she was an office manager
budget kind of person they got her great
at doing the budget and just left her
alone and let her be great at that and
then just got her better and better year
over year at that technology and she end
up saying for 26 years at same place so
I think that's the start of it and you
know be willing to look at some some
more things in the future give you out
some ideas probably in the future lab
roots let newsletter lab lead a
newsletter great sort of a follow-up to
the same subject what can I do with
employees that don't want to move up or
take on new things yeah I think it's a
first off we judge that a lot were there
a lot of high-achieving people want to
do great things on this phone call just
the fact that you would log in and want
to learn more you probably can't
understand that mindset because they're
like why would this person not want to
grow and develop so I think it's
understanding the mindset first and
foremost and saying help me understand
what by what that means you know why do
you not want to move up a lot of times
what I hear is I don't
because I see the extra hours you work
I'm not sure the pay's worth it I'm not
sure that I'm really cut out to move up
so I try to work with them to understand
there are lots of benefits by moving up
and that's just the financial it's the
chance to maybe be able to chart the
future a little bit to be able to grow
your team and learn new different things
if they're still insistent and they
haven't seen those upsides and there's
still pretty adamant then I say to them
okay then when you're in the spot you're
in how do we help you again beat the
best day in and day out what tools and
resources can we help you be the best
how do we help you master your current
job what would it take for you to become
a mentor to others if they still sort of
push back and just say you know I just
want status quo I let them know that you
know status quo isn't an option that
regardless we're going to change year in
a year out and try to ask them what
changes would they may be want to work
on our lead so it could be we're going
to get a new piece of equipment and
that's what excites them so i try two or
three times you know whether it's new
equipment or its explaining what it
takes to move up or just what is their
motivation to really get to the heart of
it so those are a couple suggestions for
them great thanks Jeff we do have time
for one last question and it's a good
one do you have any more suggestions on
time management so I can coach yeah that
could be a whole nother presentation so
what kind of tech that away with the
folks from erosion lab leaders and all
that but a quick couple of things to
think about block off sometimes I know
how busy you guys really are I see it
I'm in the labs weekly but there's still
gotta be some time that you can block
off and say you know for the next hour
I'm just going to try to focus on this
task whether it's coaching or it's doing
the budget or it's getting ready for the
next lean event trying to get better at
blocking your time additionally a lot of
the ability to coach and grow should
allow you to delegate some things so you
can go work on the next priority so I'd
also look and today are there
some things that you can be delegating
that you used to do that may be held on
too long another one is this priority a
lot of times what happens is we get
three more priorities from each area of
the hospital or the organization and so
it's going back and saying what are our
top priorities and make sure that we're
lying on that and the final one is we
say yes a lot but we don't ever think
about our nose when we say yes to things
it really means we're saying no to
developing our team or no to being able
to get that next project done or getting
that new piece of equipment up and
running and so I also have you really
ponder do i always need to say yes or
can I won't say yes a little more slowly
yes I do want to work with you does it
need to be me or it could be someone on
my team yes that is a great idea would
you be willing to scope it out for us
and then we'll get back to you or yes I
want to work with you but could you wait
a week to work with me because we got
these three other priorities so lots
more that we could talk about in that I
would recommend the book overworked and
overwhelmed by Scott Evelyn again that's
overworked overwhelmed by Scott Evelyn
he's got a lot of good time management
tips and practices in there and it
really deals with today's workforce when
we're stressed and strained by the
smartphone and all the requirements that
were that are needed so you know gave
you a few tips but Scott's got a lot of
great tips in his book as well great
that's all the time we have for
questions but I do want to thank Jeff
Smith again for bringing this
presentation to us Jeff you have any
final comments for our audience I wish
to say that the coaching is one of the
tools in your hand bag you know it's a
your toolkit should be full of lots of
great things and coaching is one that is
probably underdeveloped but don't think
that it needs to be this massive metal
work really just start to practice it
you know if you only did one thing from
the conversation today go recognize a
superstar and that's the start of
coaching and the more you do it the
better you get at it and I really
appreciate all the work that the ink
factory did it was fascinating and
watching and to see what they've done
and I think that you're going to really
enjoy the slide and i hope you tuck that
away and may that's a reminder of the
a great job from the ink factory Thanks
thank you Jeff of course I also want to
thank our sponsor lab leaders for making
today's educational webcast possible
coming up on the screen in a moment
there's going to be a video and if you
have any suggestions for future lab
leaders topics we'd love it if you could
type them into the Q&A box in the bottom
left corner love to hear from you
great I'd also like to remind our
audience to join us on May fourth for
the next installment the lab leaders
webinar series during this session
you'll have the opportunity to further
explore what accountable care
organizations population health
management initiatives are but most
importantly understand what they mean to
the lab to learn more please visit www
scom thank you again for joining us
today and we hope to see you again
goodbye